hallo und herzlich willkommen zur
heute-show unsere letzte sendung des
jahres schön dass sie dabei sind
andererseits so sollen sie sonst auch
hin wenn man sich nicht unterhalten will
bleibt ja nur fernsehen seit mittwoch
wieder harter lockdown klappe zu lesen
auch erkennen wir ja alle schon leere
innenstädte homeschooling sachen essen
die man selber gekocht hat ekelhaft was
mir auffällt zumindest im fernsehen hat
dieser harte locker und fast schon die
hormonelle nebenwirkungen oder wie will
man das hier erklären wird sich der
harte lockdown wohl so anzusehen so viel
ist jetzt klar es kommt es kommt schnell
und es kommt dicke und klar ist so hart
wie man rein gegangen ist wird man nicht
rauskommen
ich lass das mal einfach so stehen meine
damen und herren erst mal das positive
der ersehnte impfstoff wird schon vor
weihnachten zugelassen ist eine top
nachricht außerdem das waren die guten
nachrichten
schade der harte lockdown muss wohl sein
aber warum haben sich unsere politiker
über wochen so am thema weihnachten fest
gewissen nie was versprechen was man
nicht halten kann alte regel die ganze
pandemie kommunikation ist wirklich
unterirdisch muss man so hart sagen
peter altmaier sagt erst shoppen ist
patriotische pflicht jetzt sagt er
leute hört auf zu shoppen wirklich jetzt
oder hier jens spahn noch im oktober
wann würde es zum zweiten lockdown
kommen liebe julia block wird gar nicht
beziehungsweise wohl ja klingt im
nachhinein natürlich blöd immerhin sagt
iren sparen wir lernen alle dazu und
werden uns viel verzeihen müssen da ist
was dran
manches hätte man aber wissen können den
harten lockdown den wir jetzt haben den
wollte die bundeskanzlerin schon vor
wochen über die landesfürsten halt nicht
wie selbstkritisch sind die denn so
ärgern sie sich im rückblick
wir haben die falsch gehandelt
wir haben nur zu wenig gemacht war
damals auch meine strategie in der
schule
wer wenig macht macht wenig falsch was
man herrn kretschmann allerdings zu gute
halten muss ist ein grandioses gespür
für timing für die richtigen geräusche
immer zum richtigen zeitpunkt es liegt
in unserer hand ob wir die kontrolle
über das virus in den nächsten wochen
zurückgewinnen können virus kontrolle
gutes stichwort die kontrolle haben wir
verloren weil deutschland in diesem
pandemie herbst schlicht versagt ist
dass so viele altenheime sind schon
wieder corona hotspots nachdem es
monatelang hieß wir müssen die variablen
gruppen schützen haben sie jetzt erst
eine verbindliche test strategie für
heim besucher und mitarbeiter
beschlossen
und was bitte soll der bund länder
beschluss zu kontakt beschränkungen
während der weihnachtsfeiertage hier
kommt immer das versteht doch keine sau
wie wäre es denn zur abwechslung mal mit
verständlichen klaren ansagen es kann
doch nicht so schwer sein
jetzt bleibt der grundsatz übrigens zwei
personen in fünf haushalte er fünf
personen zwei haushalte ging auch das
ist zum beispiel das angebot für den
single jetzt klingt er endgültig wie
eine telefonhotline singles aus zwei bis
fünf haushalten wollen wir dir
weihnachten feiern
wer soll da noch durchblicken ich
empfehle ihnen als vorbereitung
ernsthaft die die aufgaben aus dem neuen
weihnachts corona mathebuch beispiel
aufgabe erlaubt ist die kernfamilie plus
maximal vier personen beachte eine davon
ist opa der ist witwer und hat eine neue
vier jüngere freundin so zählt die
kernfamilie oder als erbschleicher
schließlich ohne text aufgabe die
menschen in der eifel wohnen in
verschiedenen haushalten sind aber
biologisch einer kernfamilie was jetzt
aus der kelly family sind inzwischen
viele neue kelly family ist entstanden
wäre da weihnachten kommen nur die von
angelo und wie verhindert man dass maite
sinkt
die wichtigste frage totale
überregulierung von sachen die man nicht
kontrollieren kann
als start es gebe doch genug zu tun
spätestens jetzt wo fast alle schulen
wieder zu sind was in wirklichkeit auch
nicht so überraschend kommt müsste die
sache mit dem digitalen lernen aber auch
endlich mal klappen finde ich zugegeben
da gibt es wohl durchaus fortschritte
aber eben auch nicht 20 tablet computer
hat die stadt münchen inzwischen zur
verfügung gestellt doch das wlan das
schon vor über fünf jahren beantragt
wurde gibt es bislang immer noch nicht
gut das hat in dem fall aber der rektor
verbockt hat den wählern an tragen nicht
per fax geschickt ja liebe eltern ich
hoffe wirklich sie haben eine schöne
betreuungs lösung für ihre kinder
gefunden denn wie lange sich das ja
alles noch hinzieht das weiß ja in
wirklichkeit kein mensch silvester fällt
die aufseher sonnenklar und der harte
lockdown endet frühestens am 10 januar
manche gehen sogar von ostern irgendwann
ist mein letzter sozialkontakt
wahrscheinlich der typ vom lieferdienst
vieles ist gerade etwas anders aber
deine lieblings restaurants sind für
dich da wir helfen dir durch den winter
klar mit essen aber auch mit allem
anderen was du gegen lockdown kaum noch
kriegst zum beispiel abendmahl für
zuhause hostien to go komplett mit
weihrauch weihrauch unsere prekär
beschäftigten fahrer bieten dir den
kompletten lockdown service sie sind da
ein friseur ein nagelstudio und auch
sehr gern eine domina
denn die pucks haben wir auch zu
lieferando ein kleines bisschen
normalität
[Musik]
kurz gesagt wir sind geliefert was man
aber nie vergessen darf der harte
lockdown ist ja kein selbstzweck
er soll leben retten und das
pflegepersonal entlasten also genau die
menschen die sich im moment für uns alle
reinhängen wofür sie aber auch reich
entlohnt werden wenn auch hauptsächlich
mit schleim in allen im gesundheitswesen
möchte ich sagen wir brauchen sie
wir sind dankbar für ihren einsatz sie
stehen für uns in diesem kampf in der
vordersten linie dann gilt unser dank
allen ärzten und pflegerinnen dass die
leistungsträger leistungsträger eben
nicht immer die sind in anzug und
krawatte sondern die im kittel was sie
leisten ist gewaltig und ich danke ihnen
von ganzem herzen dafür wie jetzt leute
im kittel leisten mehr als leute im
anzug
das geht doch eindeutig gegen mich
quatsch die haben ja in der sache völlig
recht und außer schleim gab es ja auch
noch den pflege bonus von bis zu 1000
euro
in der altenpflege hat den tatsächlich
jeder gekriegt was ich mich frage will
ich es eigentlich in der krankenpflege
genau dazu begrüße ich jetzt die
krankenschwester birte schneider frau
schneider hallo was machen sie damit dem
ganzen geld also herr welke ersten sorry
dass ich mich nicht umziehen konnte aber
ich muss gleich direkt wieder in die
spätschicht also eigentlich die
frühschicht aber wegen der neuen 14
stunden schichten ist ja jetzt im
prinzip schon montag
mann ich bin total durch ich mache mal
kurzen power nap so zu ihrer frage bonus
super sache habe ich persönlich jetzt
leider nicht gekriegt ist aber nicht
schlimm ich habe mich bei den vielen
kollegen und kolleginnen in deutschland
wenn die in alle kriegen das geht ja gar
nicht dass wer soll das bezahlen
deswegen hat man das jetzt so geregelt
den bonus kriegen nur pflegekräfte in
krankenhäusern mit weniger als 500
betten die ganz wichtig zwischen januar
und mai mindestens 20 corona patienten
hatten oder krankenhäuser ab 500 betten
die mindestens 50 patienten hatten in
bochum hatte eine klinik besonders
pächter er hat keinen bonus gekriegt
weil die hatten 49 vorziehen
genau 1 zu wenig sie waren jetzt aber
ein witz oder
nein ich schwöre in marburg wiederum hat
ein krankenhaus genau 50 patienten
versorgt aber einige erst nach dem 31
mai entlassen nach dem stichtag deswegen
hat da auch keiner was geklickt wird
selber schuld wenn man die kurve
patienten da noch tagelang liegen lässt
nur weil die noch nicht alleine atmen
können wie viele krankenhäuser haben den
wegen sowas insgesamt in die röhre
geguckt haben über 70 prozent in über 70
prozent aller krankenhäuser gab's null
bonus keine bonusse im advent erfahren
sie warum sind sie dann trotzdem so
merkwürdig gut gelaunt na ja weil ich
kaum noch schlafen
das hilft total man hört dann
automatisch auf sich auf zu reden weil
man einfach nicht mehr die kraft hat vor
lauter schlafentzug habe ich alles
vergessen was politiker uns versprochen
haben wir müssen das jetzt auch einlösen
diese wertschätzung an der gesellschaft
wie der unseren drückt sich eben
wertschätzung euren bezahlung aus wer
war der sprechende uhr spaß
herr welke der staat tut doch was er
kann
tui zum beispiel hat vorletzte woche die
dritte milliardenspritze gekriegt warum
sich nicht einfach mal mit freuen
positiv denken ich kann doch finanziell
klar und wenn mein mann der ist
freiberuflicher musiker wenn der seine
november hilfen kriegt so im april oder
mai dann dann wird doch alles gut
nächstes jahr wird sowieso alles besser
wer weiß habe ich ja vielleicht auch
sogar mal wieder zeit zu duschen oder
unsere katze zu füttern hätte peter
schneider
hallo leute ich bin's der heute-show
[Musik]
hersteller
wenn ihr mehr heißen scheiß und liegt -
wollt dann abonniert jetzt den kanal
was zur hölle ist minimal hersteller
[Musik]